[Musique]
et on va plus loin avec à mes côtés
aujourd'hui c'est l'imam directeur du
mensuel afrique magazine bourgeoisiale
on soir face à vous virginie hertz de la
rédaction de france 24
présentatrice notamment- actuelle sur
notre antenne car obtenues emmanuel
macron de son périple diplomatique de
moscou à berlin en passant par kiev
difficile d'y répondre de manière
formelle au lendemain du retour à paris
du président français écouter le hier à
berlin et nous allons continuer d'agir
dans les semaines qui viennent avec des
objectifs simples le premier a été dit
éviter la guerre la paix et la stabilité
du continent européen sont notre trésor
et nous considérons que notre devoir est
de tout faire pour le préserver la
deuxième chose c'est consolider et
défendre à chaque instant l'unité des
européens et des alliés c'est comme ça
que nous avons préparé nos échéances et
c'est comme ça que nous avançons sur ce
chemin la troisième c'est défendre les
principes qui ont fait notre europe
durant ces trente dernières années et en
particulier le respect de la
souveraineté de tous les états de
l'intégrité territoriale du respect de
nos valeurs
hier la france 10 et miser avant tout
sur la pleine application des accords de
minsk de 2015 24 heures plus tard
l'optimisme n'est plus de mise virginie
herz c'est compliqué c'est très
compliqué parce qu'en fait c'est des
messages dans tous les sens et
extrêmement contradictoires ce soir le
ministre ukrainien des affaires
étrangères s'est exprimé et a dit à
propos des accords de minsk que il
n'allait pas être d'accord avec
l'interprétation russe de ces accords or
c'est justement tout le point le point
d'achoppement en fait d'après notamment
le correspondant de rfi radio france
internationale à kiev en ukraine on
craint finalement que emmanuel macron
nez
négocier avec la dîmière poutine une
alors c'est le gros mot sinon
finlandisation du pays et que finalement
même si l'intégrité territoriale du pays
n'est pas aux mises en cause c'est
peut-être l'ukraine in fine et qui va
devoir payer pour la ruralité contrainte
en fac gym a mis les fragilisent
emmanuel macron par le caractère
inflexible finalement de vladimir
poutine qui sitôt le président français
avait tourné les talons s'est empressé
un de bien montrer que la russie elle ne
bougeait pas et aussi le scepticisme de
certains de ses alliés occidentaux
et comme comme vous dites il ya eu
plusieurs messages c'est pas poutine qui
a dit qu'il s'était passé un porte
parole qu'il ya 10 ans parties que la
troisième non je pense on voit bien là
le positionnement et la stratégie russe
et le positionnement russe sait
aucune élargissement de l'otan à nos
frontières mais ça ne concerne pas que
l'ukraine ça concerne toute la sphère et
deuxièmement si il faut que ce soit une
discussion agressive et long des prêts
longue et pro tracter est compliquée et
désagréable elle le sera
c'est c'est clair et net donc on
comprend très bien que ce voyage n'est
pas le voyage miracle par contre c'était
le voyage nécessaires pour créer un
premier dialogue la deuxième chose c'est
qu'on prend on comprend aussi que les
russes sont un peu excusez moi le terme
emmerdé par cette approche française
parce que eux leur idée c'est de
négocier avec le vrai chef le vrai chef
c'est les états unis et ses yeux les
patrons de l'otan donc c'est cette
europe qui se re au fait qui se
reconstitue puisque même les polonais
sont revenus maintenant dans le train
stade aucune espèce de bloc européen qui
ce qui ce qui se cristallisent ça
empêche un peu la diplomatie agressive
russe de jouer donc on envoie des
messages pour dire au palais à trois
choses la question centrale c'est
qu'est-ce que l'ukraine de demain et
même les français ne disent pas
finlandisation dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui il ya des offres dans
l'avion le président d'y apparaître
finlandisation mais il va falloir
trouver un statut alors que certains en
france sur la scène politique disent oui
c'était un voyage inutile bas on aurait
bien aimé les voir et ce qu'ils auraient
pu faire que certains faucons aux états
unis en particulier ça les énerve qu un
président européen de second rang qui ne
soit pas américains prennent
l'initiative on peut comprendre et que
des va-t-en-guerre qui n'iront jamais en
guerre ça aussi c'est le losc qui est en
première ligne les ukrainiens puis
derrière les ukrainiens et à nous donc
les phrases assez sèche de poutine sur
la possibilité d'une extension du
conflit en europe elles ne sont pas
destinées à washington sont destinés aux
capitales européennes donc c'est va-t-en
guerre néo conservateurs américains qui
n'iront pas faire la guerre ça les nerfs
mais bon tant pis il s'il affirme la
voix d'une diplomatie européenne et par
là même ils s'affirment emmanuel macron
comme le diplomate en chef de l'union
européenne
virginie alors il est en ce moment forme
forcément parce que donc il est à la
tête de la france qui est à la tête du
conseil de l'union européenne angela
merkel aussi qui était la figure
centrale en europe est parti donc
effectivement il essaie de prendre le
leadership dessus cela dit ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'il a remis en selle
le format enfin le triangle de weimar
weimar donc pologne france allemagne
avec trois donc chefs d'état et de
gouvernement qui représentent plus
qu'eux mêmes puisque donc on a parlé de
la france avec l'union européenne il ya
la pologne qui est à la tête de louer 6e
et l'allemagne qui est à la tête du g7
en ce moment donc effectivement il ya
une cristallisation la diplomatie
européenne on sait qu'à chaque fois à
chaque dossier ont dit où sont les
européens les européens sont divisés etc
c'est un peu la tarte à la crème des
critiques envers l'europe mais elle est
là oui elle a réussi l'europe l'union
européenne et emmanuel macron a réussi à
la replacer au centre de cette question
qui concerne quand même ses intérêts
vitaux et sa sécurité et ce et ça contre
vladimir poutine qui essayait
effectivement des quartiers où enfin
tout simplement d'ignorer les européens
vous évoquez les sceptiques à l'image à
l'étranger mais également sur la scène
intérieure est ce que malgré ça il peut
retirer des bénéfices on est évidemment
dans un contexte électoral on en attend
d'ailleurs une une déclaration du
candidat moi je pense que c'est beau
c'est
les français sont toujours sensibles à
l'attitude d'un chef d'état qui
s'investit dans les affaires
internationales après on voit que les
préoccupations dans parade tout à
l'heure quelques minutes les préoccupent
sont pas forcément là et puis je pense
que ça perturbe son agenda politique à
lui c'est à dire que normalement là on
devrait être dans la fenêtre que lui
même avait plus ou moins laissé en temps
me février of de la mi-février d'une
belle annonce de candidature dynamique
et c est encore une fois dans l'avion
qui le ramenait entre les trois
capitales il a fait et de la fédé off
pour dire que ça posait petites
difficultés que son temps était occupé à
100% par cette affaire donc je suis pas
sûr qu'ils y gagnent complètement bon
on va voir s'il ya quelque chose qui ce
qui sort quand même de précis mais bon
sa stature de chef d'état presque
gaullien enfin poste gaullien et puis le
silence quand même s'cusez moi de d2 de
la concurrence à part à part de dire des
platitudes sur l'île l'ukraine et la
russie à rien quand il n'y a pas un son
qui serait surprenant alors il ya ceux
qui sont totalement pro russe ou quasi
pro russes comme zemmour et où comme
mélenchon enfin dont tous très bien et
puis ceux qui à droite essayait de
trouver une place en faisant des
guillemets ça passe pas quoi donc cessé
pour lui c'est plutôt politiquement
c'est plutôt positif en tout cas s'il
est un mouvement dont on imagine que
l'elysée et les autorités surveillent de
près c'est celui du convoi de la liberté
inspirée du blocage de la ville d'ottawa
au canada par des routiers hostiles à
l'obligation vaccinale des
automobilistes en colère se donnent
rendez vous ce samedi à paris une
nouvelle crise des gilet jaune à
l'horizon zyad limam
mêmes fins mêmes ingrédients une
histoire un peu différente il ya quand
même un socle anti-vaccins très très
très organisé très puissant qui se
raccroche à la la la je veux dire à la
revendication gilet jaune le coût de la
vie extra donc il y a un effet un petit
peu coalisant comme ça qui est un peu
inquiétant avait quand même au milieu
symbolique très surprenante symbolique
de la voiture qui espèce de truc là qui
au 21ème siècle alors qu'on devrait
essayer de s'en débarrasser un petit peu
on retrouve la voiture on retrouve le
camion aux états unis comme une image du
siècle précédent donc c'est clair que ça
va poser un problème c'est clair que le
timing est très politique aussi après
est ce que le mouvement est organisé est
ce que l'opinion publique globale qui
quand même et aller à la vaccination qui
a fait les deux les trois doses le test
ne passe le trait le minutes est-ce
qu'elle va être très solidaire de d'un
mouvement qui savent franchement
anti vagues sous liberté je sais pas je
ne sais pas du tout qu'elle est déjà
beaucoup de madmagz ma grande surprise
de voir que ça a l'air de prendre un peu
on verra samedi et dimanche à paris et
on verra lundi à bruxelles puisqu'après
dix mètres du box situation différent du
canada tout de même virgin hertz
puisqu'ici les syndicats de transport ou
qui ne s'associe pas au mouvement ou six
a déjà il faut rappeler effectivement
qu'au canada à la base c'est un
mouvement lancé par les chauffeurs
routiers qui avaient besoin d'un pass
vaccinale pour aller pour se rendre aux
etats-unis une grande différence aussi
c'est qu'au canada souvent les
chauffeurs routiers sont propriétaires
de leurs camions ce qui n'est pas le cas
en france et donc s'il ya une différence
après effectivement c'est la voiture
c'est le camion qui est au centre de
de ce mouvement
c'est le 20ème siècle dit vous oui mais
en ce moment avec l'augmentation du prix
de l'énergie et de l'essence on est
quand même en plein dedans et c'est ça
c'est aussi la crise économique ça veut
dire aussi des classes paupérisée c'est
ça cela dit au canada aussi une très une
très forte marque de ce mouvement c'est
que c'est un mouvement non seulement de
défiance envers les institutions et ceux
qui gouvernent mais c'est aussi un
mouvement qui est très instrumentalisé
par l'extrême droite et qui est infiltré
par les conspirationnistes de tous bords
mais à voir si en france les
configurations identiques en tous cas
politiquement se reproduit autre sujet
potentiellement explosif ici en france
le port du voile faut-il l'interdire
dans les compétitions sportives c'est
l'objet d'un amendement que des
parlementaires de droite les
républicains majoritaires au sénat
veulent d'adjoindre à la proposition de
loi issue des rangs de la majorité à la
république en marche les manuels macron
qui vise à démocratiser la pratique du
sport faut-il légiférer sur cette
question pour l'heure en tout cas elle
est laissée à l'arbitrage des
fédérations virginie hertz ou absolument
alors la
loi va être rediscuté le 24 février
définitivement est pour le moment
effectivement ces différentes
fédérations alors qu'ils décident par
exemple dans le handball en ouvrant de
boules pardon les femmes peuvent se
voiler en compétition dans le foot
fait de la gt l'interdît la fff par me
l'interdît voilà mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est que c'est un sujet de
société qui divise non seulement la
société française mais par exemple les
mouvements féministes qui sont très il
ya d'un côté les féministes
universaliste qui des skis qui pour qui
c'est une aliénation pour qu'il y ait
une émancipation comme donc b qui sont
plutôt voilà et qui est représenté et
des partis de droite si l'omission
patriarcat pour ces femmes là et on est
que ces éléments sur la suisse
inclusif qui dit qu'il faut inclure tout
tout tout les représentantes toutes les
femmes et qui voulaient leur laissez la
vivre leurs valeurs religieuses sur un
long temps critique les universaliste
comme étant des bourgeoises blanche qui
ne voient pas qu'ils ne comprennent rien
à l affaire et c'est une question qui
revient en tout cas en ce moment qui est
quand même un peu ce qu'on analyse et
politiquement on a quelques on a deux
mois des élections est évidemment cicero
mi6 et discuter s'il ya des amendements
qui ont été déposées c'est aussi pour
voilà pour pour draguer les électeurs de
droite et d'extrême instrumentalisation
politique à des fins électorales ou bien
harmonisation nécessaire finalement de
ce que font aujourd'hui les fédérations
au cas par cas mais il fallait il
fallait des sénateurs et l'eire qui ont
rien à dire pour sortir ça d'abord la
loi la première loi a là rien à voir
avec ça on parle de démocratisation loïc
correct a donc évidemment pas le on voit
quand même que c'est un coup politique
en se disant bon il faut bien qu'on
trouve un truc le hijab ça marche ça
marche tout de suite tout le monde en
parle sacré du sacré des débats
fratricide qui vont durer des semaines
et c'est
moi je suis un peu saoul et franchement
on en a parlé un peu au téléphone
aujourd'hui je suis un peu saoulé par
cette discussion qui naquit qui n'avance
à rien je pense qu'il ya des textes qui
existent qu'ils sont déjà très
contraignant pour ces femmes où ces
jeunes femmes qui veulent porter le
hijab je pense qu'on n'a pas besoin d'en
rajouter je pense qu'il ya aussi un
argument
je comprends très bien ce débat entre
les les féministes universaliste et les
féministes qui le sont pas mais pour
avoir un tout petit peu côtoyé s'agir
c'est aussi dans certains quartiers la
possibilité pour certaines filles de
sortir d'un carcan de pouvoir aller
jouer au foot de pourra jouer au
handball de et est donc si on commence à
se mêler de ça aussi on au contraire en
accentue la sensation d'exclusion et on
accentue ses radicalisation intérieur
qui sont intimes hectares je trouve que
vraiment ce n'était pas le moment quoi
merci jade voilà ce qu'on pouvait lire
sur cette question en tout cas voilà
débattues à l'occasion de cet amendement
sénatorial merci d'avoir été avec nous
merci également à vous virginie est